hello this is presh talwalkar and this
is the third video in the series of how
to solve the rubik's cube
i'm going to explain how to solve the
first layer of the cube
all right let's get started solving the
cube
the pieces are thoroughly mixed up and
now the first step in the layer method
is to create the white cross
so we're going to look for the four edge
pieces which have white on one side and
another color on another
it happens that one of those edge pieces
is already next to the white center so
here we have a green and white edge
piece
and to put that in position we simply
rotate
the top face until we get the green to
match the green center
so we've completed one
of the four
that are necessary for the white cross
so now we need to identify the remaining
three pieces
so here's another piece which is white
and red
we can identify the white and blue piece
and finally here we have a white and
orange piece
so we'll deal with this case first it's
the easiest so let's say you're looking
at orange and white is at the bottom
so you're looking at one color and at
the bottom is white
so in order to get this to the right
position you rotate it around
until
your edge piece matches the center
then you rotate
the face you're looking at two times
and that will bring the edge piece in
its proper position and most importantly
we have not messed up the green edge
piece that we had solved before
so now we're going to put the remaining
edge pieces in position
here we have blue and white and we've
moved that to the blue face
so this is like the previous case except
the two colors are flipped so we're
going to need to do something different
to get this piece in position
so in this case we do the move
down
right
front prime
f prime and then r prime
and now you'll see that the blue edge
piece has been put in position and we
haven't messed up the orange or green
pieces
so there's a final case
all right so here's the final case where
you have an edge piece that's along the
center it's in the middle layer
so how can you move this piece into
correct position
you basically want to rotate it
and now
you're basically looking at
this is the same case as the blue case
so you have the red and white edge piece
that's in position
where you're looking at the white face
so we again do
d
r
f prime
and then r prime
so those are the four cases of how you
can find the edge pieces and this is how
you put them together to be in the white
cross
all right we've completed the white
cross and now we need to complete the
four corners and put them in the correct
position and correct orientation
in one case
you may already see a corner that's in
the correct position with the correct
orientation
in that case you're lucky and you don't
need to do anything
there's another case where the corner is
in the right position but it's in the
wrong orientation
and finally if a corner is not already
on the top layer then it has to be on
the bottom layer
because the corners can only go in
certain
so
positions
going to show how you can get all of
these
edge corner pieces in the right spot
with the right orientation
so here we need to change the
orientation of this corner as you can
see it clearly changes when you rotate
one of the sides
so here's one way that you can get the
corner to have the correct orientation
the corner is in the upper right so
we're going to need to move the right
side
so we're going to go
r prime
d prime
r
and now we have the corner that's along
the bottom
and we see that one of the faces is
white that we're looking at
so if we rotate it
we find
that we'll be able to match the orange
face of this corner
and we want to move it to the top
so when you have a case where your
corner has white on one side
and is matching the other side you can
go r
prime d prime
r
and that'll bring the corner up
so that's what happens when you have the
corner on the bottom right you need to
move it to the top right
here's another corner we see a white
face and we have a blue face
so we're going to rotate it around
and now we're matching the blue edge the
blue face
to the blue center and we want to move
the corner from the bottom left to the
upper left
so we do that
with
l
d
and l prime
so we move this corner into position and
we haven't messed up any of the other
corners
so now we just have one more corner that
we need to put into place
and
i'm just going to move the cube around a
little bit because i want to orient the
corner in a certain way
so it might be the case that the corner
you're looking at has white at the
bottom
so in the previous two cases white was
on one of the sides
now we cannot match any of the sides to
the center we have green and red we
can't match it because white is at the
bottom
so in order to do this we're going to
have to change the orientation of that
corner
so when the corner is in the bottom
right
we go r prime
d prime two times
and then r
and now the corner will have changed its
orientation because we can see the white
face and now we can match the other
color to one of the sides
so since the corner is in the bottom
right we go r prime d prime
and r
so now we've solved
the entire top layer
i hope you like this video please click
through to watch the next video on how
to solve the middle layer of the cube
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory
you can support me on patreon
catch me on my blog mind yourdecisions
on twitter at presh tallwalker and you
can get my books listed on my website